all right ben
ben uh where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
uh i am originally from baltimore
maryland um
which is a pretty crazy place to grow up
i'm you know to be exact i always say
this i'm from east baltimore uh
northeast which is
you know each section is different south
baltimore east west west is at least
when i was a kid was the most
treacherous but the east side we had
shootings every day it was a pretty
crazy place
how would you describe your childhood
so
um
i had a unique childhood and i was just
talking about this with somebody last
night and i'm glad i was because it kind
of gave me an interesting perspective
before doing this
so
if i had grown up in
let's say rancho palace verdes uh a
place that i lived later in life
affluent server in l.a
exac a very affluent suburb in l.a do
you know terranea that's where i lived
next to terena uh but later in life so
anyway so if i had grown up there in
that environment
the style of parenting that my parents
employed would have worked because
my mother just let me be outside and
that's i think a really big reason why
everything ended up happening you know
and so i would just be roaming east
baltimore
every single day i skateboarded my dad
my biological father he's a piece of
[ __ ] um
he used to beat the [ __ ] out of me um
and uh he's just like a stereotypical
like coke dealing alcoholic womanizing
piece of [ __ ]
hit women in front of me beat the [ __ ]
out of me
all that good stuff you know and would
use me to to smuggle drugs when i was a
kid um
you know put them in my pet
luggage or on me physically uh when i
was like very young um
and and then my mother so like i had
like i i feel like i had like a physical
abuse side taken care of with my father
and then with my mother it was more so
just like she just let me just be
outside which like i said rpv i would
have been just skateboarding around
hanging out with a bunch of you know
cool kids that you know swimming or
something
east baltimore
that turns into
i mean just doing stupid delinquent [ __ ]
as a kid you know even like 9 10 years
old just [ __ ] running around lighting
stuff on fire but behind the school or
just dumb little kid stuff but that
elevates you know to and that's how i
got into the dealing thing is
being 12 13 years old
my peers who are in the same
circumstance as me were all just outside
10 20 of us all day all summer all of
that
and then not really having money like
that to be able to go
eat right like okay we're all outside
all day every [ __ ] day and this hot
ass summer we really need some water and
some food
how are we about to do that and so that
that's kind of like
that my upbringing was like basically in
the streets outside and very quickly
i think
11 or 12 i think was the first time i
started selling something i was trying
to remember it before i came out here to
talk to you and i can't exactly remember
i think i was 11 or 12 the first time i
was selling like dime bags
um so yeah what kind of kid were you in
high school
that's a that's a funny question i'm
actually glad you asked that i'm so glad
you asked that um
so like i think a big reason why i'm
alive and not in jail starts right there
and actually starts in middle school
so i had an english teacher in middle
school
who
he would force me to act in like plays
and stuff like that so i'd be outside in
the streets like crazy and then go to
school and i'd be acting in place dramas
and stuff
and
he had told me in my last year that if i
didn't apply to this really nice art
school for high school that he was going
to fail me and not i wouldn't graduate
so i was forced to apply
and i got in and it's this it's you know
what shout out baltimore school for the
arts
it's incredible it's the best place you
could possibly ever go to high school
there's no place better you do half your
day academic half your day
acting or drawing or dancing whatever
your uh your major is so they have all
the different disciplines
dude you can sneak out at of class and
go listen to a symphony 110 piece
orchestra i used to every lunch i would
go upstairs and i would i would
i would smoke weed in the [ __ ]
bathroom because i was a bad little kid
and then i'll go [ __ ] listen to a
hundred piece orchestra but then i'll
get out from there and i'll go back to
my neighborhood
and sell [ __ ] drugs all night till
one o'clock in the morning and go home
so it's like i had this crazy that's why
i talk like this that's why i don't talk
like everyone else from my neighborhood
i used to i used to talk like
man baltimore's got a crazy accent
[Music]
and uh
like i used to i used to talk like
really hood you know and uh
braids i used to have long braids and
all that [ __ ] but that got me out of
that environment
and got me around the art world and so
that that was my life i had this weird
juxtaposition
of going to a school with marble statues
and
two-story staircase and
um you know it's very too tupac it's the
same school that uh tupac went to when
he went when he was in baltimore all the
teachers there love to talk about it
talk about tupac running around and [ __ ]
but um
so
i don't know i would just be crazy in
the streets and then i'll be in school
having this this both worlds and i would
be doing i wrote a play that got
performed in baltimore for a short play
like a 30 minute thing
um
you know and so i was in that art world
up until
when i was maybe
like 16
um
so like i also skateboarded and this one
of the dudes that i skated with uh he
was from affluent family
and his dad died and he got left with
all this money and all this anger
and
even a nice neighborhood at baltimore
still in baltimore it's very easy
getting the [ __ ]
and he became very plugged in with a lot
of gangs and with uh with a lot of with
a lot of drugs
and he put me in a position to where um
i could get
so much stuff cheaper
than what it what it normally was in my
neighborhood
and uh so at that age 1617
uh i really started that's when i like
dove deep into it
i got into a situation at school to
where they kind of halfway kicked me out
i was only allowed to come to school
half the day every day so i'll be at
school for only till noon and then i'll
be out on the streets the rest of the
day after that
so that's when i really got deep into
into selling weed and selling like mali
you know about mali like mdma yeah yeah
um that was like molly had just come out
back then i always got i never i never
say this to anybody but i always look
back at that
and i always wonder if i was [ __ ]
selling crack
because
it was just tan rocks like my connect
would just be giving me these
tan powder and rocks and this is molly
go dude you know
and i'll go sell it then you know so i
don't know i would sell some powder and
i'd sell some weed and uh and i did my
thing and it got bigger and bigger and
bigger i i worked with a lot of guys
that were childhood friends to me so
that's just my friend right like that's
just my boy i actually i'm not gonna say
the name but like that's just my boy you
know
but oh he's a blood
and this keeps happening in my life more
and more to where by the time i was 17 i
realized like
oh wow
all my [ __ ] friends are bloods now
all my friends from my neighborhood the
the set that i'm on
is a gang and so
it really got cranked up you know
because gang banging plus selling drugs
is a is really
it's a pretty crazy
there's a lot going on all the time
every day
and uh you know we start
feeling like we need to have guns
because we're having more money and
you know so we're 16 year olds buying
guns which is not a good
thing you know and um it just escalated
and escalated to the point where we're
doing five or ten thousand dollars a day
in mostly weed sales in like a big
section of east baltimore
and uh it just got to a point to where
uh it just got really hot
ironic with the police going by there
you go um
those guys the guys that just rolled by
they were giving us a lot of trouble
um
uh you know we'd be getting raided and
just kind of like it was so hard to keep
on on top of things and uh and and then
just so basically there's all this stuff
going on and then one random summer day
some of the homies from my my hood like
i was so naive man my homeboy told me
you need to carry a gun you need to
carry a gun you need to carry a gun
i i told him
like literally i thought this i actually
thought this
bro the hood loves us
the hood loves us who everybody loves us
the [ __ ]
no they don't
i was a kid and i was so naive
and so yeah a couple of the home the
homies you know a couple of the people i
thought were the homies set me up right
on my mom's porch
uh you know robbed me for like an ounce
of weed
it's nothing you know three four hundred
dollars gun in my face all that
and um
pistol i i beat my head in and [ __ ]
stomped on my ribs and when he went to
to [ __ ] shoot me in my head
it
i think his [ __ ] misfired or uh like
didn't fire
and so uh
you know he runs up off my porch
i'm all [ __ ] up my mom's
watching through my [ __ ] win through
the from the living room my mom's
screaming at this [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
off my porch what the [ __ ] get off my
son
you know
watching her son about to get killed
basically and uh
and so i didn't get killed she gets me
inside bleeding [ __ ]
a bunch of broken ribs some idiot
stomping on my ribs
um
and uh and so the very next day
she sent me to l.a uh like like
instantly she was like you're i had got
parents out here in um
redondo beach so now you know that's a
pretty affluent area too so get away
from the hood go to redondo beach
and uh
so she uh the next i like the girl i was
dating at the time come meets me at the
airport we're like crying in the air for
you know all this [ __ ] i'm thinking i'm
never gonna see anybody ever again it
was you know it's like it's so dramatic
like obviously i went back and visited a
million times but in that moment where
somebody just tried to kill you and your
mom's like you gotta leave you know it
felt so dramatic i thought i was never
gonna see anyone again
um and so yeah that's when i that's what
sent me out out here
so you hear me california what age that
oh yeah yeah good point um i was so i i
think i had just turned 17 and so
i couldn't yeah so yeah so that's what
ended me up in inglewood so
um
i couldn't get an apartment i'm staying
with my godparents and we're like oh
yeah [ __ ] he's a child kick an apartment
this is an issue and you know like
they're they're great people but it was
uh
steph and dave i love you i can say
their names
um
that you know it's a one bedroom
apartment in [ __ ] redondo beach and
i'm like [ __ ] a teenager big
rambunctious weed smoking you know
[ __ ] from east baltimore
and uh so they they finally find me this
spot in inglewood
i'm so glad you asked us because it's so
funny in baltimore you know in a
neighborhood it's bad
all the buildings are boarded up there's
[ __ ] if you know it like that you
know it's bad
it's like down here like this is what
baltimore's like
inglewood doesn't look like that you got
palm trees you know i can say this
because uh so i was across from alondra
park
i thought this is nice park apparently
that's where like all the gangs hang at
is alejandra park so i was i was right
there i think some people consider it
like on the edge of inglewood but i was
right there by uh
uh el camino college and the ramonas and
all that right there
and so i'm thinking i just palm trees
golf course something i just moved to
such a nice area
and uh immediately i just
start falling back into the same old
[ __ ] and it's like
it's totally based on like where you are
and who you're around you know like and
i know that from going to art school
when i was at art school i wasn't
[ __ ] doing any of that i was
acting
um
i thought i was gonna go to college
there was one little thing actually i
can't can't blame myself for this i was
supposed to get into this college and
then they rechecked my transcripts and i
had a d in chemistry and i couldn't go
to the [ __ ] school because i had this
one d in one class so now i'm out in
allen california and i'm not going to
school either so it's like just the same
old thing again like all right i'm not
in school i'm out on the streets all day
you know and i don't know maybe i'm just
making an excuse to be completely honest
maybe i just wanted to do that [ __ ] you
know it was fun it was fast money it's
in your blood it is i mean i did it
since i was a baby my dad did it
um
other people in the family did it but i
got you i'm not gonna say say who you
are right now
a lot of people in my family did it and
oh and that's one other thing too is so
i had an uncle that lived in norcal all
the way up in um
humble up by ukaya and redway and all
that and so
so i could get so so i'm automatically
plugged in he's and he's and he's a weed
grower so it's like okay i'm in la i
cannot like it's just i'm [ __ ]
of course you know i'm just of course
i'm gonna end up doing it so
uh the thing to remember in this story
is that weed was illegal oh yeah really
quick weed was crazy illegal if i would
have got caught with even so we did get
caught back in the day yeah thank you so
much for reminding me of that so
just in all that baltimore [ __ ] like an
ounce of weed were in jail i mean we
would get caught
we the police would hop out on us every
day and think about this like uh so me
and my boy i'm gonna just say hey
you know who you are my boy but i don't
want to put you out there like that
because i bet you're still in the
streets my boy
um we were the only two white boys in
our neighborhood that was in the streets
so think about when the cops
they know us they pull up on the block
those two white boys
get them so i mean and like he didn't
have the benefit of going to like a
better neighborhood school or whatever
so he'd really be getting jumped out on
all the time weed was super illegal weed
was crazy illegal it when i look back on
it it's like we walked around every day
with the equivalent of super smelly
cocaine on us
like like cocaine worth of charges that
everybody can smell so it yeah it was it
was crazy and even coming out so then
when i came to la weed is medically
legal out here and my uncle who's a
grower in norcal he supplies uh
dispensaries and [ __ ] but we'd still
illegal in baltimore and
so that yeah so and the big thing that
uh
my uncle showed me
because like uh when i first got here i
was like oh can you connect me
and he was like yeah i'll just mail you
some pounds like
mail me some pounds you know what uh you
know it's super scary the first time
but he did he just mailed some pounds
down to my house
and that was it
you know it made me realize
i can i can send this wherever i can
send this to baltimore i can send this
to
a whole lot of places
um
and uh one of my friends from back home
i mentioned to this to you earlier had
become like a pretty large
dealer um
really really really big deal he was
moving a ton of wheat he would be moving
50 100 200 pounds of weed every week
i'm not even gonna say a nickname
because
but uh
my boy uh
my boy lama that's his that's one of
that was our special name for him my boy
lama
i knew that he could move anything i
could get him so like if i were to get
him 50 pounds i knew that he he'd pay
for him and
do his thing with them and so
for a long time
i just really only worked with him you
know i just really
because i couldn't even get enough for
him you know like he was moving so much
that even my best efforts was a fraction
of of everything he needed
um
and so i'd be mailing mailing stuff over
and then um
back then uh bank accounts are different
so you could uh
yeah everybody knows this that was in
the streets back then you could put
money into people's bank accounts uh
without you didn't have to have an id or
anything like you could have just walked
into bank of america with my account
number five grand in cash boom put it in
no questions asked and i'll put it in
now it's not like that at all anymore
and so but back then so we just mail
pounds over to whatever state and they
would be putting money into your bank
account you pull it out
and it's that easy and ups or usps is
delivering your your [ __ ] ten
thousand dollar box of weed in two days
you know
um
what changed though is uh is though the
money thing so they started requiring
ids and things of that nature for
putting money in the bank
and that's
uh that's when i started flying
to go get my money and because i would
fly to go get my money now instead of
just this one isolated person in this
say texas or maryland or the eastern
shore um
that i'm working with now i'm in this
state and i'm meeting all these people
and i was really cocky crazy you know i
was a i was a [ __ ] like
19 year old kid touching hundreds of
thousands of dollars so if somebody said
oh who's this guy what am i gonna say
i'm the plug you need pounds of weed
you know like an idiot
um
but yeah so that's really that's i think
that's really what actually grew it it's
kind of ironic like they limited our
ability to put money into the banks and
so that would you think that would like
decrease it
uh but because of then me flying to go
pick up my money in person and fly back
with it now i'm meeting 10 times more
people and they all need the same thing
and so
um around the same time while i'm living
in inglewood
all right i have to be very particular
now so i meet
a bunch of folks from a gang um
because like right i'm working with my
uncle up until this point so i've got my
uncle we'd send it right but he's just a
hippie you know he can only do so much
on his hippie farm he's older guy
you know so that's that i've got like a
bottleneck you know i can only get so
much weed for this tremendous amount of
demand all you know so many different
states
and uh and so like simultaneously two
things happened
all my little homies that had been like
two three four years younger than me in
high school they're all up now they're
17 you know 16 17 18. so i can put them
on now and they're they're starting to
and so now not only my network is bigger
their [ __ ] network so now it gets
crazy hundreds of people i'd say 150 200
people that are all
buying at least five to ten thousand
dollars worth of drugs when they re-up
or when they when they do their purchase
so now it's a lot of money and then
within that maybe 20 people that are
that are that can spend infinity money
you know any amount of what they want
that you can get they'll buy all of it
and they'll haggle the price and they'll
buy a million dollars worth so at that
point
it's it's
it was [ __ ] crazy it was [ __ ]
crazy it was like
it just got it got [ __ ] crazy because
there's so many we're all kids we're all
all a super tight-knit group of kids
getting a lot of money shipping a lot of
pounds to a lot of places
um and then
so and and
the gang that i met
had connections with other
organized crime groups i think is the
best way to put it so the gang that i
met had connections with
cartels and mafias right so
bigger than gangs basically all the
organizations that get bigger than gangs
and they would have older uncles or
older or just big homies and [ __ ] that
would be in these these umbrella bigger
organizations and so now
in cali my access to [ __ ] is everything
[ __ ] anything and at the best price
and pretty much unlimited quantity too
if we just we might have to go to a few
different places but we can get all of
it so now
[ __ ] gets really crazy
um
i definitely won't say his [ __ ]
name but my big homie i hope you see
this bro with a l
bro i love you i miss you i hope you're
doing good
um
i met a dude over in vegas
um
who could take
i could drive him ten thousand pounds of
mexican brickweed and he'd buy all of it
i could drive him
yeah
infinity weed and he would buy infinity
weed i've never seen street money like
this in my entire [ __ ] life uh that
like
this dude had every car this dude had
the fir the first day i met him we go up
in this condo and we're going to show
him a sample of the stuff that we can
bring him and then we're going to bring
him thousands of pounds of it we go up
in this condo it's [ __ ] beautiful
everything is perfect everything's done
you know everything's perfect
and i said hey man like i really
appreciate you doing this like this is
the first day you're meeting us i i
can't believe you bring us in your home
like cause people won't do that you
don't bring people in your [ __ ] home
ever let alone the [ __ ] day you meet
them
he he's this bit he's jacked he lets out
this like big billowing laugh and he
goes
this is my house it's my dog house
there's only place my girl doesn't know
about
that kind of money
and
so yeah so just it just took off it just
got it got [ __ ] crazy you know it got
to the point where we're just just all
day every day all i do the same way you
just said you work a 15 16 hour day
every day i'd be doing that on the road
as soon as we get this from here to
there we got to go back here and we got
to get the money back you know because
now we're trafficking big amount big
amounts of money and so you can still
get [ __ ] on the way back with all the
money um
and i'm catching cases just to clarify
too i'm catching i used to joke from 18
to 21 i would catch a case every three
months i would catch a big [ __ ] case
and and the homies are catching cases
and
but
until the other [ __ ] drugs started
affecting us
we were good
we would bail each other out
like we had love like i was in my
homeboys car one time when i caught this
big trafficking case in baltimore they
raided my grandma's house they [ __ ]
cut all his seats open in his car that i
had
took his car all this [ __ ] same home he
came and picked me up from jail it's
straight [ __ ] happens bro you ain't cut
my seats they cut my seats you ain't
tell them to you ain't telling those
drugs in the car or some [ __ ]
so it's like we had a lot of love for
each other and we would do what the [ __ ]
ever for each other would bail each
other out we would get lawyers for each
other so nobody got [ __ ] like i i
caught cases like crazy
i probably
just in tennessee i spent
with my with my homeboy
you know who you are too we both spent
like 50 on bail like 50 000 on bail
attorney
and uh and and then uh we we both paid a
few thousand dollars in in fines for the
situation at the end so it's like we
spent like 50 just in tennessee and
while i had that case in tennessee i was
on trial in virginia
and baltimore and the girl i was dating
at the time had took a case for me in la
so three trials put so four trials in
tennessee included i'm out on three
different bales which i don't even think
you're [ __ ] supposed to be able to do
but it was three different states so i
don't think they knew
and then my girl i'd gotten in a caught
in a car with 20
i got caught in a car 21 pounds this is
a [ __ ] ridiculous story we're driving
three blocks we're going from my house
to her house i got 21 pounds of weed in
the car there's another 15 pounds of
weed in her ceiling at her house and we
have to just go there vacuum seal it all
and ship it out right
on the two [ __ ] block drive we get
pulled over get the car rated they go
and raid her house because i guess they
look at her id or some [ __ ]
all 41 pounds of weed all taken the cops
going oh this is cartel level this is
cartel level i'm laughing
no it's not
no it's not i've seen cartel level it's
um it's this whole building full
um
and uh and so i we you know she kept it
[ __ ] solid shout out to you hon
lady your nickname lady uh thank you i
love you thank you for taking that case
i would have went to the [ __ ] prison
if you didn't take that case and so she
said they were all hers she took like 40
40 something pounds for me so now i'm
i'm paying for her bond her attorney
i've got three cases in all these
[ __ ] states my homeboy just got
locked in sacramento my big homie uh and
he had to do house arrests in sacramento
the reason you're telling this story now
is the statue of limitations yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah the only reason i
could tell this is because i'm 26 now
and i stopped trafficking drugs
by 21 basically like i i still did
little things in la at 22 like say go up
to a farm get 100 pounds go to a
dispensary but i don't think that's
illegal it might it was gray area back
then because there wasn't no license for
that but that's that's where i went to
is like okay i'll go get a hundred
pounds but i'm going to dispensaries i'm
not going to [ __ ]
out there but yeah so i mean i don't
know so i caught a million cases all the
homies caught a million cases um
i can say this we we started we were
selling only pot that that's what to say
so we started dealing with some other
stuff
um
i think the best way to put it
you know for me like i really could get
so much money out of weed that it i was
never as as like i didn't have to get 10
000 xanax and do whatever with them
because i had so much money off weed i
was straight
the homies though
only so many of the hundred homies can
be the ones breaking down the weed you
know what i mean not all of them so
it kind of got to where like zans and
some other stuff getting involved and
the biggest thing that was crazy about
that and it's like
it's like i watched karma happen
it's like i watched karma happen because
you get these [ __ ] drugs right like
we doesn't [ __ ] people's life over we
doesn't ruin people's lives that's why i
feel good selling it
um zans do especially fake xanax with
fentanyl on them um and coke and
crack crack really [ __ ] does
uh and heroin really does
um
and so it progressed like the homies
started dealing with tens of thousands
of zans and boom now they're all on zanz
so they're selling zans they're losing
their money i don't know if you know
about xanax but it makes you forget
especially if you abuse it in like
really high dosages you'll you'll have
three or four days where you have no no
memory of what the [ __ ] you did so
you'll wake up no money
you know or you're in you wake up in
jail not knowing the [ __ ] happened so
that's what starts happening when this
when they start importing
all these tens of thousands of xanax and
they're getting a hell of money off of
it but
all my homies life starts going down the
drain
losing everything crashing all their
cars everything ever like one of my
homies crashed one of my bmw's up in
baltimore that i didn't have no [ __ ]
insurance on at the time that he
shouldn't have been driving
a couple of my homies they were all
[ __ ] up on zanz one night they go out
and they they they they shot up this
whole neighborhood they shot up this
whole [ __ ] neighborhood they didn't
kill anybody nobody they shot like cars
and [ __ ] like stupid like shot out
shot up cars and [ __ ]
but they were off like xanax and and
liquor i stayed home they were like you
want to come right out with us i slept i
wake up the next day they're back and
then later that they're on the [ __ ]
news from this whole neighborhood got
shot up because they went and did this
[ __ ] off the xannies
as you can imagine that's not conducive
to [ __ ] business that doesn't really
lead to
at least the cops and stuff you know it
doesn't really lead to conducive
conductive for business sales a couple
of homies got in shootouts at the time
like they were just living so crazy and
reckless which like i've never been in
no shootout i don't i've never [ __ ]
had to shoot at somebody i keep a gun
not
not right now because they're in la i
don't have no gun on me in l.a but
you know i like to keep a gun on me or
whatever but i'm not trying to [ __ ]
shoot at anybody and so the homies are
getting into shootouts all this crazy
[ __ ]
and um
catching cases it gets worse and worse
uh and the more drugs they get involved
the more they just on the drug so
they're selling them but now they're on
coke and zannies and this and that one
of the big homies um
who's trying to get me and like my l.a
boys to get involved in heroin
trafficking he's asking us to get him 30
[ __ ] bricks of heroin which like
i do do you understand that's that's
crazy you know what i mean like
10 pounds of weed that's 20 21 grand
right 23 grand
30 keys of heroin i don't even know it's
like a million and a half dollars or
something like i i don't even know i
know keys of blow are like 30. i don't
even know what keys of heroin are
um
and it just got to be too much man like
he got knocked on that he went we told
him no me and my boys from l.a we
thought about it and we were like my
homeboy had just had a baby
you know who you are boy bro c and l
love you guys miss you they they used to
live with me them their baby mamas and
their baby dudes from the gang that i
told you about the
you know
uh the gang that i would be around their
baby mama and their babies um
i love those guys and they just had kids
they're like [ __ ] this [ __ ] we're not
about to try to sell no [ __ ] heroin
so they told them like go get the bricks
on your own we're not getting any bricks
of heroin he goes somewhere in norcal
gets knocked 30 30 keys of heroin trying
to buy him
boom that [ __ ] baltimore up he was one
of the big cats in baltimore and now
he's out of the picture and his partner
they got this crazy crazy crazy crazy
beef going
and they split
um
he runs with one of the major major
gangs out there
uh very dangerous fella so that just a
lot of beef starts going down
uh
homies [ __ ] homies up homies pulling
guns on each other homies almost killing
each other
a lot of times homies almost killing
each other
rock crazy [ __ ] kicking each other's
doors to get money back that they [ __ ]
over like all the drugs man it makes you
act like a [ __ ] idiot
and so
at the end of it it just all came to a
head like
it was so shady everybody's going to
jail everybody's killing each other well
not not actually killing each other but
like one and two
wanting to kill each other really like
that's what's so crazy like when people
ask me like oh like your friends or
whatever i always say a bunch of my
homies went to jail a bunch of my homies
died and and
the rest of us we want to kill each
other because of stupid [ __ ]
so it's like everything is just [ __ ]
the big network was ruined there was
nothing left
we couldn't keep getting money together
people were oding and [ __ ]
and um
i just like
the the last the last catalyst i had
this one guy was like my brother he
would hold me down in baltimore like he
made sure that i was straight you know
and he was very serious he moved a lot
of jamaican he's funny man he's a white
dude like me and he moved with nothing
but jamaican dudes they loved him and uh
he was very serious and he would handle
business but you're working with the
cartel
and that
you don't just stop that right
yeah
so
well so this is what i'll say and i have
to see i love you for the way you did
this and i never understood the way that
you did this until recently so there was
a dude with that uh that really was like
my main homie here and he introduced me
to everyone else and what i realized is
i never did a meeting with anybody that
he didn't set up
i didn't set up no meetings i didn't
so it was
it was i was like a step removed even
though i'm there in doing every single
thing
my homeboy c is conducting the
orchestration of the business the how
much money for how much this i don't
speak spanish that's another thing i
realize a lot of these cartel dudes the
uppers they'll [ __ ] speak english
dude you have to speak spanish with them
and i knew a degree to which so i could
know the numbers right so i know that
the numbers that i'm being told are the
same as the numbers that they're
speaking but i can't [ __ ] have a
whole kind to get you to trust me and to
to interact with me
um one of the things they would always
have me like do a bump of coke because
they the the agents undercover agents i
guess won't do won't actually consume
drugs so any time i walked into one of
those buildings i had to they would be
like hey you want to bump a coke
take take the bump of coke
um
but yeah no i mean i think the way the
reason i was waiting able to walk away
from it is like the same thing that
caused our downfall right if everybody's
in jail right if everybody's drugged out
out of their mind they only remember
what the [ __ ] they did yesterday
and that's the thing like i think that
if i would have been directly with the
upper dudes the cartel dude say i spoke
spanish and i'm really just none of my
none of these younger guys are with me
i'm just going there i think it would
have been a major difference but luckily
it was all their nephews i would be
going with their nephews and i think
they just kind of and then all their
nephews are [ __ ]
i don't know not to say it just drugs
lean and zans because not the hate i
love you guys um
lean and xanax will really put you in a
dispos and liquor altogether it's just
you'll be so cloud you'll be talking to
people that aren't there you know and
that's kind of where the homies got to
so it's like
how like
maybe i don't know it's hard to like
go trip on somebody like yo why why are
you not selling for us anymore it's like
bro i can't even have a coherent
conversation with you to to go to the
plug with you you know what i mean so
so you moved where
so i moved
out uh about as far about as far away as
i could on the east coast to a state
where marijuana is legal to open a
cannabis business and that has turned
into
the best decision i made in my [ __ ]
life dude
you're aware now
uh
east east coast is that oh you want to
be
okay is that okay this is fine yeah i
can i can be a little more specific
okay okay yeah yeah i'm i'm on the east
coast in a legal cannabis state and uh
so yeah so basically what i did is i ran
the [ __ ] away and you know this i
mentioned it a minute ago uh i ran the
[ __ ] away man so after my homie got
raided uh by the dea in baltimore and
now that's what's saying liam he was my
best guy in baltimore so like
baltimore's just done it's dead
everybody's [ __ ] on drugs jail
um all the girl man
man girls i thought was down for me then
turned into hoes mark
[Laughter]
man the woman i thought was down for me
done turned in the hose mark oh my god
so it's like there ain't nothing left
for me there
go [ __ ] some girl that three of the
homies is [ __ ]
go try to sell a pee to some
nodded out [ __ ] whatever
and uh
and then and then [ __ ] got hot in la and
the homies are all [ __ ] up the police
are waiting i'm running away i'm i told
you every couple days i'd walk in my
[ __ ] house i'd be bugging out i'd
just be [ __ ] sitting there bugging
itching bugging bugging pack up the
house [ __ ] run away
and so uh
that that was it i ran away to the east
coast i started a dispensary
last five years done nothing but that
sold legal weed and you did it illegally
though yeah man i made my escape dude
what would you say is the most important
thing you learned in all of this
craziness
i think it's really about like where you
are and who you hang with so
any place that you live there's bad like
there's good and bad people right like i
met really good people in the hood so
it's not like just living in the hood
it's just bad people right
but
it's really just like you gotta just
move yourself like you gotta you gotta
decide to
make the change and like the change can
really be
based off where you are and who you're
around like at the end of the day
the best decision i ever made in my
entire life
was to run away from everything
all my friends and my whole network
everything my whole life everything that
meant anything to me and to start fresh
and that was the best thing i ever did
in my life and
so i guess yeah i guess be willing to
to just start fresh and to just focus
to focus on you and your goals instead
of the people because i think that's
really what it was is i was so addicted
to the network and hanging with the guys
and hanging with the girls and
if you can just get away from everything
all the [ __ ] that you're surrounded
by and just focus on what you actually
want to accomplish
that's the best thing i ever did
[Music]
all right ben thank you so much for
sharing your story mark thank you good
to see somebody getting out yeah it's
it's hard cost a lot of money too i'll
tell you i spent every penny that i ever
made in that whole trafficking thing on
licenses and lights and this and that
but
made it all back once i did it
you